Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Sadzak.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Hauptsache jemand guckt nach mir.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Kurt Bergmann.
Herr Bergmann.
Ja.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen bestabieren?
Ja, der Vornamen ist ganz kurz.
K-U-R-T, Kurt und Bergmann.
B-E-R-G und dann M-A-N-N.
N-N, okay.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin jetzt 55 Jahre alt.
Noch und ich bin geboren am 5.07.1970.
Könnten Sie Ihr Geburtsdatum wiederholen bitte?
Am 5.07.1970.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,75.
Wie viel wegen der Suzerheit?
82 Kilo so ungefähr.
83. Okay, vielen Dank für diese Informationen.
Herr Bergmann, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also einmal tut mir mein Handgelenk unheimlich weh.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ja, ich habe mein Motorrad rausgeholt.
Es ist ja so schönes Wetter gewesen.
War mit dem Motorrad wieder unterwegs.
Und dann hat es mich in der Kurve, ja, bin ich hingefallen.
Also nicht voll Speed, aber ja, das Motorrad ist halt umgefallen.
Und ja, ich habe jetzt auch Schmerzen in der Brustwand.
Also insbesondere wenn ich einatme, habe ich Schmerzen.
Aber so arg ist mein rechtes Handgelenk.
Der rechte Arm, der tut mir sehr weh.
Seit wann?
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Na ja, seit dem Unfall. Das ist jetzt zwei Stunden her.
Ich konnte die Maschine noch bis nach Hause schieben.
Und bzw. fahren.
Und konnte wieder aufsteigen, aber es tut jetzt doch hellisch weh in der Hand.
Ja, das tut mir leid zu hören.
Haben Sie recht gelenk Schmerzen und Brustschmerzen?
Was habe ich?
Zurzeit haben Sie recht in der rechten Hand.
In der rechten Hand, ja, also die tut sehr weh, ja.
Und Brustschmerzen.
Ja, beim Einatmen insbesondere, da tut es sehr weh, ja.
Wie statt sind Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Von eins bis zehn.
Also die in der Hand sind wirklich sehr heftig.
Also würde ich schon sagen, so bei acht sind die wahrscheinlich, ja.
Brustschmerzen?
Ja, die sind vielleicht nicht ganz so doll.
Wenn man nicht so tief einatmen, wenn man so ein bisschen flach atmet, dann geht es.
Aber wenn ich tief einatme, sind die schon auch ganz schön doll, ja.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Geschmicks aushalten oder möchten Sie...
Ja, so lange wird das ja jetzt nicht dauern, ne?
Okay.
Haben Sie offene Wunde?
Ja, so ein bisschen Haut habe ich mir abgeschürft, ja.
Ich hatte also eine Jeans an und eine Lederjacke, aber am Bein ist so ein bisschen Haut abgeschürft.
Und die Handschuhe hatte ich zwar auch an, aber ja, insbesondere am Bein ist ein bisschen Haut abgeschürft, ja.
Und was ich auch gesehen habe, also am Brustkorb rechts, da ist es schon ein bisschen blau geworden.
Da habe ich wohl ein bisschen was abgeschürft.
Und die Hand, also die Hand, die tut eben sehr weh und das ist auch alles jetzt schon ein bisschen so angeschwollen, ne?
Und das tut wirklich ordentlich weh, ja.
Ja, ich werde diesen Bereich kontrollieren. Machen Sie sich da keine Sorgen.
Haben Sie Kopfverletzung?
Na, ich hatte ja den Helm auf, also ja, ohne Helm fahre ich nicht.
Also da habe ich glaube ich nichts abgekriegt. Nee, der Kopf tut mir nicht weh.
Haben Sie bewusst sein verloren?
Nein, nein, nein, auf keinen Fall. Also ich habe das alles mitbekommen, bin ja auch noch wieder aufgestanden, ja.
Haben Sie keine Blutungen?
Bitte was?
Haben Sie keine Blutungen oder?
Also ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen. Wie gesagt, so ein bisschen Haut abgeschürft am Bein und an der Hüfte.
Aber das blutet nicht doll, also das ist nur so ein bisschen, ja, dass die Haut da halt kaputt ist.
Leiden Sie unter Fieber, Nachschweiß, Schüttelfröschen?
Nein, ich bin ja normal kein gesund, also ja, ziemlich gesund, ja.
Okay. Haben Sie Hüsten?
Hüsten? Nee, Hüsten muss ich jetzt eigentlich nicht, nee. Und ich würde jetzt auch ungern husten, weil das Atmen halt ein bisschen weh tut.
Denke ich mal, Hüsten würde wahrscheinlich auch weh tun, ja.
Leiden Sie oder haben Sie Taubheitgefühl oder Kribbern im betroffenen Bereich?
Ja, also die rechte Hand, die kribbelt tatsächlich so ein bisschen, ja. Jetzt würde ich sagen, hm.
Haben Sie Bewegung im betroffenen Bereich?
Ja, ich kann die Hand überhaupt nicht bewegen. Das tut ja höllisch weh.
Ich kann die nur, also ich stütze die mit der anderen Hand so ein bisschen ab, aber ich kann die überhaupt nicht bewegen. Die tut furchtbar weh.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Naja, ich glaube so der Schreck direkt nach dem Unfall, da hatte ich wahrscheinlich schon so ein bisschen Herzklopfen, aber das ist jetzt, würde ich sagen, das habe ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay. Ich habe vergessen, Herr Bergmann, wie haben Sie zu uns?
Wie sind Sie zu uns gekommen?
Ja, wie sind Sie zu uns gekommen?
Ja, meine Frau hat mich mit dem Auto gebracht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nee, schwindelig würde ich sagen, ist mir nicht, nee.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Also ich habe eigentlich immer so ein bisschen schnelle Verdauung, also so, ja, also ich habe häufig mal Durchfall, aber jetzt ist mir nichts Besonderes aufgefallen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit oder bei der Unfall ungewöhnlich Wasserlassen oder?
Nee, also ich habe mich jetzt nicht angepinkelt oder so, nee, nee.
Also ich war einmal zu Hause auf der Toilette, ja, aber ich habe nur Wasser gelassen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Sehstörungen oder Hörstörungen?
Nee.
Okay.
Also hören kann ich richtig und gucken kann ich auch gut, ja.
Haben Sie irgendwo chronische Krankheiten, zum Beispiel Blutpockdruck oder Krankheit?
Nee, ich habe sogar eher niedrigen Blutdruck.
Das habe ich jetzt schon ziemlich lange und da nehme ich Tropfen ein, aber jetzt fragen Sie mich jetzt nicht, wie die heißen.
Die stehen zu Hause auf dem Frühstückstisch, aber ich kann Ihnen jetzt gerade nicht sagen, wie die heißen.
Also ich habe schon ein bisschen Beschwerden.
In der Halswirbelsäule habe ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Da will ich mich aber nicht operieren lassen.
Da habe ich irgendwie zu viel Angst.
Das macht mir halt hin und wieder Schmerzen.
Meistens geht es ganz gut, aber manchmal muss ich halt Medikamente einnehmen und die rechte Schulter, da habe ich eigentlich auch schon seit Jahren immer ein bisschen Schmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Also diese mit der Bandscheibe, das ist so seit fünf Jahren.
Ich habe die erste Erkrankung nicht gut verstanden.
Aber ein Bandscheibenvorfall in der Halswirbelsäule.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden an niedriger Blutdruck, oder?
Ja, niedrigen Blutdruck habe ich, ja.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Diagnose?
Nein, also es ist halt bei mir so, ja.
Also der Blutdruck ist relativ niedrig und deswegen nehme ich regelmäßig so Tropfen ein, die den ein bisschen nach oben machen.
Ok, danke.
Haben Sie weitere Erkrankungen?
Ja, also in der Kindheit hatte ich krass Neurodermitis und jetzt habe ich immer noch so ein bisschen Hautveränderungen an den Oberarmen außen.
Und da nehme ich halt, wenn das zu sehr juckt, nehme ich so Cortisonsalbe.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Oh ja, ja. Das ist jetzt pro 25 Jahre her.
Da hatte ich einen Sportunfall und da ist mir die Achilles-Säne gerissen.
Und das ist wieder genäht worden und da bin ich operiert worden, ja.
Vor 25 Jahren, können Sie wiederholen, welcher Bereich?
Die Achilles-Säne ist gerissen.
Welche Seite?
Auf der linken Seite.
Hier wurde eine operiert.
Das wurde dann genäht, ne?
Ok.
Herr Bergmann, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, wie gesagt, diese Blutdrucktropfen da, die den Blutdruck steigern sollen, dann habe ich diese Cortisonsalbe.
Und ja, wenn die Schmerzen vom Hals da oder von der Schulter zu stark sind, dann nehme ich auch mal Ibuprofen ein.
Ibuprofen.
Kennen Sie Dosierung Ibuprofen?
Oh, ich glaube, das sind 600er. Dann nehme ich dann eine, ja.
Wie oft nehmen Sie Bluthochtropfen und Ibuprofen?
Also diese Blutdrucktropfen, die nehme ich jeden Tag. Aber wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Jeden Tag. Wie oft nehmen Sie Bluthochdrucktropfen?
Die Blutdrucktropfen nehme ich jeden Tag. Das Ibuprofen nehme ich natürlich nur, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Dann habe ich Sie gerade falsch verstanden. Das Ibuprofen nehme ich nur bei Bedarf.
Ja, aber Bluttropfen verstehe ich nicht.
Die Tropfen, die den Blutdruck nach oben machen sollen.
Ah, okay. Sind bei Ihnen Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, man hat mal festgestellt, dass ich eine Kontrastmittelunverträglichkeit habe.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, da habe ich Ausschlag bekommen. Mir ist ganz heiß geworden.
Und dann hat man mir halt gesagt, dass ich das auf keinen Fall nochmal wieder haben darf.
Ich habe richtig verstanden. Hautausschlag.
Und Hitzegefühl.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Bergmann?
Ja, aber ich rauche jetzt nur noch wirklich ganz, ganz wenig. Ich habe das sehr reduziert.
Ich habe viele Jahre lang ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht. Aber jetzt, seit vier Jahren, rauche ich nur noch ganz paar Zigaretten am Tag. Vielleicht so fünf am Tag.
Seit fünf Jahren?
Seit vier Jahren. Und vorher habe ich halt wirklich 20 Jahre lang ordentlich gekleidet.
Da habe ich 20 Zigaretten am Tag gut weggepackt.
Aber seit fünf Jahren rauchen Sie fünf Zigaretten täglich?
Seit vier Jahren, ja.
Okay, das ist sehr gut für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol süßig?
Also ich trinke jeden Abend trinke ich eine Flasche Bier.
Aber wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt, auch noch mal vielleicht ein Glas Wein oder zu einem sehr guten Essen ein Glas Wein. Aber eigentlich bin ich eher Biertrinker.
Trinken Sie täglich ein Flasche Bier? Seit wann?
Ja, ungefähr so kann man sagen.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Seit ich erwachsen bin.
Okay. Nennen Sie bitte die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage. Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen nehme ich nicht. Nein, nein. Kann ich mir gar nicht erlauben. Nein, bei meinem Beruf.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie jahrelang chronische Erkrankungen?
Chronische Erkrankungen?
Also mein Vater hatte vor zehn Jahren Herzinfarkt und ist daran gestorben. Aber das ist ja keine chronische Erkrankung.
Und meine Mutter, da hat man jetzt vor ein paar Jahren an der Schläfe hatte die so einen weißen Hautkrebs, der ist wegoperiert worden. Aber sonst ist die eigentlich fit.
Wann ist Ihre Mutter operiert? Nein.
Das ist jetzt so drei, vier Jahre her. Und die passt jetzt halt ein bisschen auf mit Sonne und trägt immer einen Sonnenhut im Sommer oder so.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Eine Schwester habe ich, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Die ist tatsächlich nicht gesund. Die ist mager süchtig. Und die wiegt also pro 45 Kilo oder so.
Magersicht meinen Sie anoroxyne rosa?
Ja, so heißt das glaube ich.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder. Die sind auch noch alle zu Hause.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind alle gesund, ja zum Glück.
Okay, Gott sei Dank. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf, Herr Bergmann?
Ja, ich arbeite als Tierpfleger hier im Zoo. Es gibt hier ein Zoo und da arbeite ich als Tierpfleger.
Ich füttere die Tiere und mache sie sauber und misste aus. Wir gucken, dass es den Tieren gut geht.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Treffwetter?
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht. Manchmal ist es so ein bisschen stressig.
Im Frühling, wenn die jungen Tiere kommen, dann muss man auch mal nachts da sein, wenn die großen Tiere ihre Kinder kriegen.
Aber normalerweise ist es eigentlich eine sehr schöne Arbeit mit den Tieren.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, ich wusste nicht. Wir haben einmal eine Fahrt nach Amsterdam gemacht.
Da war ich mal in Holland, aber sonst war ich nicht weg.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, im Besonderen Tetanus?
Tetanus bin ich natürlich geimpft. Klar, bei dem Beruf, das wäre ja sonst sträflich.
Natürlich bin ich auch gegen Corona geimpft, mit der großen Familie. Da sind wir alle geimpft.
Perfect. Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, die Kinder halten einen natürlich in Trab. Bei der Arbeit ist es auch viel körperliche Arbeit.
Insofern ist da nicht so viel Energie für Sport über. Aber wenn das Wetter gut ist, dann fahre ich auch ganz gerne mal Fahrrad.
Mit wem wohnen Sie? Mit der ganzen Familie natürlich.
Herr Bergmann, ich habe meine wichtigsten Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie noch etwas um mich zu fragen?
Nein, ich habe Ihnen jetzt sehr viel gesagt. Es geht ja jetzt überwiegend um meine Schmerzen, die ich habe.
Ja, ich kümmere mich um Sie. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Zunächst werde ich Sie eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Das ist gut, wenn Sie mir eine Schmerzmittel geben. Ja, ich glaube so langsam wäre es ganz gut.
Ja, das ist alles. Danke. Alles klar. Gut. Soll ich dann ins Wartezimmer gehen?
Nein, bitte legen Sie sich auf die Liege. Ich höre Sie körperlich um die Person.
Gut, möchte noch jemand etwas fragen? Na ja, er war sehr vollständig. Ich wüsste nicht, dass er irgendetwas nicht gefragt hat.
Ich hatte eine Frage. Doch, jemals hatte ich eine Frage.
Ich nehme an, waren Sie auf dem Nicht-Arbeitweg, oder?
Ach so, doch. Ich war auf dem Weg von der Arbeit nach Hause, ja.
Und wann war Ihre letzte Mahlzeit?
Wann habe ich denn zuletzt gegessen? Ja, wir haben noch einen Kaffee getrunken bei der Arbeit.
Vor dem Feierabend. Aber da habe ich nicht viel gegessen. Da habe ich nur Brötchen gegessen.
Ja, aber das ist um 4 Uhr gewesen. Ja, vielen Dank. Und noch eine Frage.
Leiden Sie unter einem Kribbeln oder ein Taubweißgefühl im betroffenen Bereich? Ich meine ein Handgelenk oder...
Ja, das hat er aber gefragt und das habe ich auch bestätigt. Ich habe gesagt, die rechte Hand kribbelt ein bisschen, ja.
Entschuldigung, habe ich... Ja, ist ja gut. Vielen Dank. Gerne.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen? Natürlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob es gefragt wurde. Wie war der Sturz?
Warum haben Sie gesturzt? Wie war es? Warum bin ich hingefallen? Ja, können Sie das kurz erklären?
Ja, also ich bin rechts abgewogen und da ist der Hinterreifen weggerutscht.
Entweder war ich zu schnell oder es war irgendwie Laub auf der Straße oder so. Jedenfalls hat es mir das Hinterrad weggezogen.
Und dann bin ich halt auf die rechte Seite gekippt. Okay, danke schön.
Wissen Sie, wie schnell haben Sie gefahren? Sind Sie gefahren? Ja, also ich war nicht schnell.
Um die Kurve donnern Sie ja nicht, wie verrückt. Sonst hätte ich mir, glaube ich, auch mehr wehgetan.
Ich denke, dass ich so mit 20, 30, ja vielleicht so 30 um die Ecke gefahren bin. Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie eine Atemnot? Atemnot habe ich nicht, aber ich habe Schmerzen, wenn ich einatme.
Ja, einatmen Sie haben gesagt. Aber Atemnot, also ich kann atmen, aber es tut halt weh. Tut weh, okay.
Ich wollte auch dieselbe Frage stellen. Okay, gut.
Ein knisterndes Geräusch an der Haut habe ich nicht gemerkt, nein. Okay, danke schön.
Kannst du losgehen, Dr. Asa? Ja. Ja, gut. Ich kann anfangen. Ah, okay.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarztin, Frau Oberarztin. Ja, hallo. Hallo. Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte ihn Ihnen vorstellen. Hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ja, erzählen Sie, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Unser Patient heißt Kurt Bergmann. Er ist 55 Jahre alt, 1,75 Meter groß und 83 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Bergmann stand heute aufgrund seines zweisichtigen Begegnungs,
der Schmerzen nach einem Motorradunfall aufgetreten. Motorradunfall, okay.
Motorradunfall aufgetreten und der Patient wurde zu uns mit seiner Frau gebracht.
Der Patient und seine Frau wurden ins Krankenhaus gebracht.
Der Patient wurde von seiner Frau zu uns mit seinem Auto gebracht.
Außerdem klagte der Patient über am rechten Hande Parasiten und Parasiten und Parasien.
Grubbelparasiten.
Zudem teilt der Patient mit, dass er unter Konklusion und Oedema, blau, Fergus, am Bein, am Hüfte und Thorax.
Er hat eine Prällung oder so etwas.
Die Schmerzintensität des Handgelenk wurde von den Patienten mit 8 von 10 Schmerzskalen bewertet.
Außerdem klagte der Patient, dass sich die Brüsse beim Einatmen verschlimmen.
Die Fragen nach Brüssseinverguss, Sehstörung, Höchstörung, offene Wunde wurden verneint.
Die Vegetativeanemnese ist unaufällig bis auf Tachycardie.
Im Bezug auf Vorerkrankungen leidet der Patient seit 5 Jahren an Diskusprolaps im Halswirbelsäurebereich.
Außerdem leidet der Patient seit seinem Kind an Neurodermitis.
Seit der Kindheit?
Seit seiner Kindheit.
Bei den Patienten wurde vor 25 Jahren wegen einem Sportunfall eine Operation im Achillentendon, linke Seite hinter dem Fuß.
Die Achillessehne?
Achillis, ja. Operation durchgeführt.
Besonders der Medikation nimmt der Patient die selbe Begründung.
Und Bluthochtropfen bei Bedarf.
Was für Tropfen nimmt er bei Bedarf?
Täglich.
Was für Tropfen sind das?
Bluthochtropfen.
Was hat er denn mit Blutdruck?
Blutdrucktropfen.
Er nimmt Blutdrucktropfen. Was hat er denn? Hat er einen hohen Blutdruck?
Leidet er unter Hypertonie?
Nein, gegen Hypotonie.
Hypotonie, ok.
Hypotonie. So wie Ibuprofen 600 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Der Patient hat Kontrast mit Tell- und Verträglichkeiten, die sich durch Exanthemum und Hitzegefühl auswirken.
Durch was äußert?
Durch ein Hitzegefühl.
Durch ein Hitzegefühl, ah ja.
Herr Bergmann raucht seit vier Jahren täglich fünf Zigaretten.
Er hat zuvor 20 Jahre lang täglich 20 Zigaretten geraugt.
Er trinkt seit seinem Junge an Flasche Biathäbisch, Drogenkonservatoren.
Sein Vater ist vor zehn Jahren an Myokartinfarkt verstorben.
Seine Mutter leidet. Seine Mutter hat eine weiße Hautkrebsbasalium.
Seine Mutter hat Basalium und sie wurde vor drei Jahren eine therapeutische Maßnahmen durchgeführt.
Ah ja, ok. Also wahrscheinlich operiert, ne?
Aber zurzeit ist sie gesund. Herr Bergmann hat eine Schwester.
Er hat eine Schwester, die an Aneroxia Neurosa leidet.
Herr Bergmann ist verheiratet und hat drei gesunde Kinder.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unaufällig. Der Impfstatus ist aktuell.
Er ist Tierpfleger und lebt mit seiner Familie zusammen.
Tierpfleger und lebt mit der Familie zusammen, ok, ja.
Wilde Tiere zu Hause, drei Kinder, ok.
Frau Oberarztin, die an der nächsten Schlange von Deutschland am Hesten auf eine Handgelenkfraktur hingeht.
Ja, oder was könnte es sonst sein? Alternativ, differenzialdiagnostisch?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kann ich sagen, Handgelenkdistorsion.
Ja, genau. Und was muss man noch prüfen?
Oder Pneumothorax.
Ah, Pneumothorax, ja, ok.
Und Rippenfraktur.
Rippenfraktur, ja. Was könnte noch im Armbereich, wo Bericht ist da besonders leicht?
Unterarm.
Meinen Sie Armfraktur?
Ja, ja, unterarm. Das ist ja eigentlich so eine Sollbruchstelle, wo es immer ziemlich schnell bricht.
Ich kann sagen Radius-Distalfraktur oder Radius-Distalfraktur.
Ja, so was könnte es auch sein.
Gut, und ja, Rippenfraktur könnte es sein und Pneumothorax, ja.
Jetzt, was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ja, Frau Weiß, um meine Verdachtstdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst die beiden Patienten die Vitalparameter kontrollieren und einige körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ja, was machen Sie denn im Einzelnen?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob es Farbveränderungen gibt.
Ja, die sind ja zu erwarten. Die muss man halt angucken, genau, die Farbveränderungen.
Denn das wird ja wahrscheinlich schon blau unterlaufen sein oder rot unterlaufen sein.
Oder Schwellungen.
Schwellungen, ja. Da hat er ja schon gesagt, dass seine Arm geschwollen ist.
Außerdem würde ich eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Motorik, der Sensorik oder die anderen Funktionen vorliegen.
Ja.
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung...
Worauf achten Sie noch bei der Körper? Sie haben gesagt, Sie prüfen Vitalparameter.
Wonach gucken Sie da insbesondere? Denken Sie mal an das Thoraxtrauma.
Ja, ich inspisiere den Patienten beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen.
Und danach würde ich die Lunge und das Herz von Patienten auskultieren.
Auf alle Fälle. Und das checken Sie noch?
Um mögliche Pathologien, Geräuschen zu beurteilen.
Ja, zu beurteilen.
Außerdem parpiere ich die Rippen und um mögliche Frakturen feststellen.
Ja. Was sind denn sichere Frakturzeichen?
Es gibt vier verschiedene Punkte. Zum Ersten offene Wunde.
Dann ist es offensichtlich. Ja klar.
Zweitens Röntgenaufnahme.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Drittens Bewegungsstörungen.
Ja, Bewegungsstörungen kann man ja auch so haben.
Was ist denn insbesondere... Ich mache mal so.
Wenn es übermäßig beweglich ist.
Wenn ich einen langen Knochen in die Richtung irgendwo drehen kann, dann stimmt etwas nicht.
Dann hat eben jemand nach etwas gefragt. Was hören Sie?
Sichere Frakturzeichen. Was hört man?
Repetition.
Ja.
Wenn es knirscht, dann ist die Knoche durch. Keine Chance.
Ja, das ist genau so.
Natürlich sieht man die Fehlstellung.
Fehlstellung bzw. Abnormen, Beweglichkeit.
Aber natürlich ist der freundlichste Nachweis über das Röntgenbild.
Dass man im Röntgenbild sieht, dass da eine Fraktur ist.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt mit Ihrem Patienten weiter?
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Was sollten Sie vielleicht im Hinblick auf den Thorax noch machen, außer Auskultation und abtasten?
Was sollten Sie noch machen? Denken Sie an Vitalparameter?
Meinen Sie körperliche Untersuchung?
Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Wenn Sie Vitalparameter checken, was gucken Sie da auf?
Bei der Vitalparameter?
Ja, ich zeige Ihnen mal einen Finger.
Puls kontrollieren?
Den Puls, ja. Und die Sauerstoffsättigung.
Wenn der tatsächlich einen Pneu hat, dann merkt man ja, dass die Lunge nicht gut arbeitet.
Dann hat er wahrscheinlich eine schlechte Sauerstoffsättigung.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt noch weiter mit Ihrem Patienten?
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich Blut abnehmen.
Was lassen Sie untersuchen?
Jetzt würde ich Blutbild aufbauen.
Dann würde ich die Erinnerung abnehmen.
Ja, ist das denn sehr wahrscheinlich?
Ja, Erinnerung ist natürlich wichtig, ja klar.
Blutgruppe ist auch wichtig, falls der auf den Tisch muss.
Ja, das lassen wir auf 5.000.
Was machen Sie sonst weiter diagnostisch?
Ja, danach würde ich eine Bidiavende diagnostisch durchführen.
Zum Beispiel Gönnken-Thorax in zwei Ebenen.
Und was noch?
Gegebenenfalls würde ich eine komputerische Domographie des Thorax durchführen.
Und was machen Sie mit der Hand?
Ja, im betroffenen Bereich würde ich die Hände, Gelenke und Röntgen veranlassen.
Gut, wenn es sich bestätigt, dass der Patient eine Fraktur hat,
sowohl Rippenfraktur als auch Armfraktur, was würde man dann tun mit ihm?
Was kriegt er für eine Behandlung, Therapie?
Bei diesem Fall würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Zunächst würde ich einen Velosanzugang legen.
Und eine Anarchistik verabreichen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und ich würde einen orthopäetischen Konsil anfordern.
Auf alle Fälle, genau.
Dann sollen die gucken, was sie mit den Knochen machen.
Und was macht man mit den Rippen?
Rippen, das ist eine gute Frage.
Wobei es kommt natürlich ein bisschen darauf an, je nachdem nach Röntgenbild.
Aber was ist eigentlich das Problem bei der Rippenfraktur?
Ich empfehle den Patienten körperliche Schonung.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und eigentlich macht man das doch konservativ.
Die Rippen, da kann man ja nichts machen.
Die kann man ja nicht eingipsen.
Der Patient muss die Schmerzen aushalten und warten,
dass seine blöden Rippen wieder zusammenwachsen.
Natürlich muss man ihn aber dabei unterstützen,
dass er das Atmen nicht vergisst.
Dass er also nicht zu sehr schonet.
Der braucht also Physiotherapie und vielleicht auch Atemgynastik speziell,
damit der nicht praktisch in so eine Schonatmung verfällt.
Was muss man mit dem Patienten noch machen?
Der kann ja nicht viel machen mit seiner Rippenfraktur.
Wird er erst mal eine Weile im Bett liegen?
Was müssen wir also auch machen?
Empfehle den Patienten Nikotinkarenz.
Oh ja, das ist nicht schlecht.
Und dich dabei? Was machen wir noch?
Atmung, ich weiß nicht.
Denken Sie mal an die Thrombose-Prophylaxe.
Der soll Heparin kriegen.
Weil er erst mal immobilisiert ist durch seine Rippenfraktur.
Wenn Sie ihn stationär aufnehmen,
dann ist er erst mal mehr oder weniger immobilisiert.
Das heißt, das darf man nicht vergessen.
TvT-Prophylaxe.
Gut, dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihren Röntgenaufnahmen rauskommt.
Ob der alles tatsächlich gebrochen hat oder vielleicht nur Prellungen.
Lassen Sie uns auf alle Fälle die Röntgenbilder zusammen angucken.
Und so, wir kommen zur Manöverkritik.
Sie haben gemerkt, dass ich ein bisschen Probleme habe, sie zu verstehen.
Insbesondere bei unserem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch ist mir aufgefallen,
dass Sie sehr viel auf Ihren Zettel geguckt haben und mich noch weniger angeguckt haben.
Das heißt, da war die Verständigung noch schlechter.
Ich kann das mehrfach nachfragen.
Aber das ist natürlich, wenn jemand so auf sein Zettel guckt.
Dann versteht man sich nicht so gut.
Sie machen eigentlich gar nicht so viele Fehler sprachlich.
Es ist nur, die Verständlichkeit ist nicht so gut.
Sie haben einen relativ ausgeprägten Akzent.
Und ich kann den nicht beschreiben.
Ich kann das auch nicht nachmachen, dafür kann ich es zu schlecht.
Aber es ist ein bisschen schwierig, sie zu verstehen.
Und sie hatten natürlich auch ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, mich zu verstehen.
Beim Fragestellen, beim Arzt-Patienten-Gespräch waren Sie sprachlich deutlich besser und sicherer.
Weil Sie natürlich derjenige waren, der das Heft in der Hand hatte.
Sie waren derjenige, der fragte.
Und Sie haben dann eigentlich auch sehr schnell reagiert, als Sie gemerkt haben,
Die Frage nach Fieber und Nachtschweiß, der Patient kommt ja nach Unfall.
Die ist ein bisschen sinnlos.
Das passt nicht so gut dazu.
Die Fragen müssen sich eben schon ein bisschen orientieren an den Symptomen,
die der Patient jetzt im Augenblick mitbringt.
Und an dem Geschehen, und das ist eben ganz einfach, ein Unfallgeschehen.
Da sind diese vorhergehenden Sachen nicht so interessant.
Und Sie haben ja zum Beispiel auch jetzt nicht gefragt, was ja auch völlig richtig ist.
Hat er in letzter Zeit zu oder abgenommen? Ist ja völlig birnig.
Interessant sind natürlich diese Fragen, ob er See oder Hörstörungen hat.
Das sind natürlich relevante Geschichten.
Oder ob er ohnmächtig war.
Das sind natürlich entscheidende Fragen, die mit dem Trauma zusammenhängen.
Oder könnten zusammenhängen.
Besonderheiten beim Wasserlassen.
Das könnte ja sein, dass er zum Beispiel sagt oder dass man fragt noch,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen, als Sie auf der Toilette waren, ob der Blut im Urin war?
Nach Trauma nicht ganz unmöglich.
Aber offensichtlich hat er ja das meiste irgendwie an seiner Hand abbekommen und am Thorax.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das Frageding war ziemlich logisch.
Und da sind Sie auch systematisch vorgegangen.
Frage nach den Lebensgewohnheiten.
Also Nikotin und Alkoholkonsum haben Sie auch schön ein bisschen eingeleitet.
Fand ich schon okay.
Was ich allerdings so ein bisschen bemängeln würde,
müssen vielleicht auch die Kollegen jetzt gleich mal sagen, was Sie dazu meinen.
Ich würde bei einem Patienten, der klagt über Thoraxschmerzen bei der Inspiration,
da würde ich schon sagen, Moment, wir unterbrechen mal eben hier unser Gespräch.
Und ich gucke mal eben, wie das bei Ihnen mit der Atmung ist.
Und wir machen vielleicht sogar ein EKG oder ich heuch sie einmal ab.
Ja, was wäre jetzt für mich interessant, was die Kollegen sagen.
Ich denke schon, dass man bei so einem Traumapatienten, wenn der Brustkopfschmerzen hat,
dass man da unterbrechen sollte.
Ja, ich stimme Ihnen zu. Es könnte vielleicht primatörlich sein.
Eben, genau. Und da müsste man ja dann auch gesellschaftlich intervenieren.
Sie haben das selber als Diagnose, ja sogar als Differentialdiagnose gesagt, den Pneu.
Also das wäre sicherlich in der Prüfung ein Punkt, dass man unterbricht und sagt,
wir gucken mal eben erst und dann schauen wir gleich weiter.
Und nach dem Arm, den stellen wir jetzt natürlich ruhig, aber da schauen wir im Detail später danach.
Gut. Gerade diese Fragen nach Lebensgewohnheiten, nach familiären Vorerkrankungen,
das sind natürlich Sachen, wenn es um die Wurst geht, wenn es also darum geht,
dass einer keine Luft mehr kriegt irgendwann, sind die nicht mehr so relevant.
Sondern da muss man eben erst das andere abklären und wenn man dann merkt,
okay, der ist stabil, da ist nichts, dann können wir weitermachen.
Gut. Natürlich sollte man bei diesem Patienten speziell,
der ja auch angibt, dass er niedrigen Blutdruck hat, sollte man den Blutdruck auch mit kontrollieren.
Gut. Ja, dann das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch. Da ist mir aufgefallen, da waren sie sprachlich deutlich weniger souverän.
Und wie gesagt, sie haben sehr an ihrem Konzept geklebt, haben immer nur auf ihren Zettel geguckt.
Sie haben mich gar nicht angeguckt. Und da ist mir dann auch aufgefallen,
dass das mit der Schilderung dieses Unfalls, das hätte ich mir ein bisschen ausführlicher gewünscht,
dass man eben nicht sagt, der Kompf, weil er seit zwei Stunden Schmerzen hat,
sondern er kommt bei Zustand nach Motorradunfall, er ist bei geringer Geschwindigkeit auch die rechte Seite gekippt.
Das gehört ja praktisch dazu, damit ich verstehe, was der Patient haben könnte.
Und insofern ist der Unfallhergang immer, wenn es um Unfälle geht, eine sehr wichtige Information.
Das sind ja auch Dinge, die zum Beispiel bei der Übergabe vom Notarzt an den behandelnden Arzt in der Pflege,
dem handelnden Arzt in der Klinik immer mitgegeben werden, dass da gesagt wird, wie war der Unfallmechanismus?
War der selber der Fahrer, war er Beifahrer? Mussten wir den irgendwo rausholen oder was auch immer?
Also Unfallhergang spielt eine ganz wichtige Rolle, damit man versteht, was für ein Verletzungsmuster sein könnte.
Insofern wichtige Information. Und natürlich wäre auch wichtig gewesen, der Oberärztin zu sagen,
dass der Patient bei seinem Unfall natürlich einen Helm getragen hat und dass er keine Kopfschmerzen, keine Nackenschmerzen hatte.
Und dann das mit den Hautprellungen, das haben Sie ja gesagt. Er hatte eine Lederjacke an und Handschuhe,
aber das hat ihn nicht geschützt mit dem Motorradsturz. Gut. Okay.
Und ja, ansonsten haben Sie ja beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch das auch alles einwandfrei wiedergegeben,
wo intensiv die Schmerzen waren. Was Sie, glaube ich, nicht gesagt haben,
was Sie nicht gesagt haben, dass die Thorax-Schmerzen bei Inspirationen verstärkt sind.
Oder vielleicht haben Sie es auch gesagt. Kann ich mich gerade nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Sie haben leichte Thorax-Schmerzen. Der Patient hat leichte.
Keine starken. Ja, die sind leichter als die Handschmerzen. Das stimmt. Ja. Aber er sagt, wenn ich ein Atmen tue, tut es weh.
Ach so, ja, genau. Sie haben gesagt, er hat eine Tachikalie. Das hat er aber nicht behauptet.
Er hat es nicht gesagt. Sie haben ja gefragt, müssen Sie irgendwie schneller atmen?
Da hat er gesagt, es tut weh beim Einatmen, aber daraus haben Sie eine Tachikalie gemacht.
Quatsch, Herzklopfen. Quatsch, das Herzklopfen. Er hat gesagt, nach dem Unfall, da hat er sich natürlich erschrocken.
Dann hatte er Herzklopfen, aber jetzt hat er kein Herzklopfen mehr.
Also insofern, das passt ja nicht so ganz.
Ja, die Neurodermitis haben Sie erwähnt, den Bandscheibenvorfall und den Blutdruck haben wir gehabt.
Und genau, Zustand nach Achilles-Szenen-Ruktur links vor 25 Jahren, was operativ versorgt wurde.
Genau. Gut. Und ja, nachher die diagnostischen Maßnahmen, da haben wir uns ja so ein bisschen vorgearbeitet.
Aber da merkte man eigentlich auch, dass Sie sprachlich auch ein bisschen Probleme haben, haben Sie selber gemerkt.
Ja, das war nicht so souverän. Jetzt muss ich dazu sagen, ich weiß natürlich nicht, ob es in Reutlingen überhaupt Traumafälle gibt.
Das ist ein Münchner Fall. In München gibt es Unfälle.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie das in den anderen Prüfungssituationen ist.
Ich weiß, in Düsseldorf gibt es kein Trauma. Aber ich denke mir immer, selbst wenn wir in der Prüfungssituation kein Trauma haben werden.
Nein, es gibt in Reutlingen.
Bei Ihnen gibt es das, ja, siehst du. Dann ist es tatsächlich elementar.
Ich finde vor allen Dingen, dass es fürs Leben wichtig ist.
Wir können nicht nur internistische Fälle üben, wenn Sie nachher sprachlos vor einem Traumapatienten sitzen und nicht wissen, was Sie ihn fragen müssen und was Sie Ihrem Kollegen sagen müssen.
Insofern, Sie lernen ja nicht für die Prüfung. Klar lernen Sie für die Prüfung. Aber Sie lernen ja auch hinterher für die Arbeit, für die Praxis.
Nons coles et vitam, disquimus, sagt der Lateiner. Ja, wir lernen nicht für die Schule, sondern fürs Leben.
Sie müssen das können. Sie müssen das können.
Und insofern ist ein Traumapfall, denke ich, für Sie alle nicht ganz umsonst. Ja, gut.
Ja, ich kann...
Es war ein bisschen anstrengend. Sie haben viel Zeit gebraucht. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Ja, wir waren ziemlich langsam mit allem. Und ja, insofern ist der Abend jetzt lang geworden.
Und es haben sich auch mehr und mehr Kollegen verabschiedet. Ja, gut.